[Arabic recitation]
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
The next point that the author
makes is how the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam instructed that the bottoms of
one's shoes be purified.
Person looks at the bottom of the shoes
sees that there's some kind of neessa
here. How should that person go about
purifying it? Do they scrub it? Do they
wash it? Do they power wash it? Do they
send it to the dry cleaners? They throw
it away and get a new pair of shoes.
What is it exactly? He says,
for.
[Silence]
He says on the authority of
who narrates that the prophet Sam
said if any of you comes to the masid
then let him before entering the masid
look at the souls of his shoes and if he
sees
any filth that has found its way into
the soles of his shoes then he is to rub
the soul hole in the dirt and then make
salat in them. So here we don't even
have the use of water. Right? Here we
don't even have the use of water. Now
remember we mentioned by any means
necessary. So as long as the nasa is
gone that's all that matters. Here's the
question. What about if a person were to
use a
used water?
Well, that's acceptable. However, is it
necessary? No. And if a person were to
use water because they see that this is
not enough, that is a bigger problem.
Because the prophet
said
he says whoever
looks for a sunnah other than mine that
he is not of me. There is a difference
between
doing something because of
circumstance
and
finding that the sunnah is inadequate or
not enough etc.
So for instance this is a good example
of this. It is enough
legislatively
in Allah's estimate that a person rub
the shoe in the dirt and make salah.
However, is it possible that a person
may find that that's inadequate
for some other reason? Let's say for
instance a person has
very deep tread
in his shoes.
Tread
And that neessa has found its way into
the into the minutia or into the details
of that tread to a point where it needs
some other kind of
you know some other kind of method in
order to ensure that it is done away
with. Is that acceptable? Sure. That's
that is a circumstance which is a very
specific circumstance
but for the general purpose rubbing it
in the dirt is good enough.
However, there may be a circumstance
where we may need to go beyond that or
there may be a circumstance where we
need to go
a little bit less than that, but not
for legislative reasons.
Not for the purpose of pleasing Allah.
We don't have to ever go past this for
the purpose of pleasing Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
Right? Is that clear? I think I think
it's clear the distinction there.
So,
so
he says
the next is purifying a piece of ground
that nas As has come in contact with
[Silence]
for
this narration. I think many of us if
not all of us is familiar with
on the authority of
he narrates that a bedin man bed man
these are people that live out in the
desert they are so detached from society
that they almost have a different set of
rules they almost live in a different
universe
and so their customs vary radically
and they are not as refined as people
who are more accustomed to living
around other people. They are naturally
offensive. They're naturally crude.
They're naturally rough around the
edges. However, it is unintentional.
what we may or what a person in in the
city or a person who is more refined may
see as a deliberate act of disrespect to
them. They do not see it as being
anything at all. It is no type of
communication.
And so this person
got up and
urinated in the masid. Please turn this
fan on. Urinated in the masid.
This is interesting. Urinated in the
masid.
Yes. Urinated in the masid for a number
of reasons.
Number one,
for the
for the bedins.
Okay.
Urine is not quite as big a deal.
Urine is not not as quite as a big a
deal and it's not necessarily a sign of
disrespect
in bedin culture. person urinates
anywhere
even revealing a person's private parts
even all of this is something that as we
said unrefined
another thing
is that
the masid itself was not carpeted was
not an an necessarily an interior the
masid itself
did not have gates or doors on it. So
there were doors to the masid. Those
were just openings in the wall for a
person from the outside to get to the
inside. There was no
there is no doors. There's no locking up
the masid. There is no right. As a
matter of fact, the masid was basically
walls and most of it had no ceiling.
And so it was very common in the
prophet's time saiam
for wild animals to be in the masid
especially at night and sometimes dogs
or you know cats or snakes and so
forth. They would get in the masid. They
would sometimes urinate in the masid. It
was common. It was not uncommon. The
ground of the masjid was
slightly more refined than the ground
outside. Slightly meaning that the big
major rocks were removed and it would be
it would be swept on a semi-regular
basis.
And so to a bedin
the masid represents a place that a
person sits in the shade. That's about
it.
And so we see here that it is possible
for the bedin, a person who who does
such a thing. There's two possibilities.
Number one, he is a bedin and he's
behaving as bedwins do and he means no
disrespect. It is an issue of ignorance.
Number two, he is trying to actively
communicate his disrespect to us.
Based on that the reaction will be
differing. Correct?
And so the companions of Allah
out of jealousy for their masid
they took hold of him and
started to you know become aggressive
with him. And the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. Now in this wording of the
narration the author doesn't mention any
of these details
but we will mention those details. He
says that was remove don't stop him let
him finish. Okay. Because now we have
two
two evils that we are presented with.
One is worse than the other. Either we
can have the urine, the nessa localized
into one place and then deal with it or
we can have it all over the masid as he
runs away
urinating wherever he runs and as they
chase behind him. So those are two
evils. Which one do we take? The lesser
of the two evils.
Leave him. Let him finish.
So after that
he
told the companions to take a bucket of
water and to pour it on the urine to
pour it on the earth. That was it. That
was the extent of purification.
what does that do? It dilutes it.
Makes it go into the ground. That's all.
and it purifies the most superficial
layer of the ground which is all that
we need.
In a continuation of the narration, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said to the
man, "Come here." He said,
He said the masid is just not
appropriate for those kinds of things.
Rather the masid was built for the
recitation of the Quran, the remembrance
of Allah and salah, etc.
Why? because he is distinguishing for
this man the difference between the
masid and a place where people would
just go to congregate and hang out or a
building in the marketplace. This may
even be acceptable in some marketplaces
where this man has gone
right and so this is why the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam told him
this. This is an incredible level of
restraint.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam teaches
us here to give the benefit of the
doubt to be gentle with one another
especially with those who are don't
know. My question is let's say this
incident happened says okay we all go
home next day rolls around
the same beduin man is there and then he
gets up and urinates in the masid again
what would the reaction be in that
situation
[Arabic recitation]
understand the prophet Sam
specifically
would his reaction be the same.
What about the third day when he comes
back? Would it again be let him finish?
Is this how it would have been dealt
with? Absolutely not.
Because there's a difference between
dealing with ignorance and dealing with
ignorance,
right? There's ignorance, lack of
knowledge. Ignorance, a
a
purposeful
intent to offend and be controversial
and so forth. Now, I'm not saying he
would have killed him or strung him up
or anything that. There are other
ways that he would have dealt with this.
However, the initial benefit of the
doubt would have receded.
[Silence]
and
alhamdulillah.